tens of thousands of people have been
taking part in gay pride celebrations
around the world including a boisterous
party in Mexico rainbow flags and
umbrellas suede and music pounded along
Mexico City streets with couples
families and activists seeking to raise
visibility for sexual diversity in the
country other LGBTQ celebrations took
place from India to Europe with more
events taking place today
activists in Istanbul were also hoping
to celebrate pride today but authorities
in Turkey have banned the event for more
I'm joined by Jones
what's happening where you are there is
a massive police presence all around the
centre of the city now to prevent the
celebration of pride but despite that
activities are still going on there are
many right these on the streets we've
backed up by water cannon but as you can
hear
people in the sample the LGBT ruling are
determined to celebrate part this is a
fourth year in a row deprived has been
found after it was initiated back in
2003
it certainly sounds that people are in
Turin terabyte goodness and there's been
some discussion about lifting the ban on
the pride march in istanbul what about
the rights of the LGBT community in
Turkey at the moment she has never been
banned even the way back to the
formation of Republic in 1923 in fact it
was way ahead of many Western
democracies on that level
well the LGBT movement it has been very
difficult to express their sexuality in
public and we've had vanished wide Gate
where LGBT Pride busyness so far so
important
[Applause]
Lewin kind of mustard
the 2014
but since then there has been a
financial and lbz to move has always
been quite to challenge that if the
election of the new mayor or position
met for the first time in 25 years there
was hope that this bound would be lifted
and there if a millimolar did say he
would speak with the governor to lift
this ban obviously those efforts have
failed but the community here are still
determined to show very visible we've
been Istanbul and in Turkey during joins
thanks so very much for that information
and also for battling with the noise
that you're dealing with apologies for
our viewers if he couldn't quite clearly
hear join